[Musique]
adame Jup bonjour vous êtes ici à
l'université de versaill saint-canttin
vous avez accepté de parrainer dans
rentrée solennelle de la de la Faculté
de Droit euh quand on lit votre votre
livre une histoire française d'ailleurs
les les mots dans ignement d'éducation
revienne assez souvent c'est quelque
chose vous dites même vous avez été un
père parfois un peu absent mais vous
avez veillé quand même à ce que vos
enfants suivent des études vous même on
en reparlera après est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu' fond
l'éducation c'est un devoir pour pour
l'État pour les jeunes et et puis que au
fond l'intelligence c'est au fond notre
richesse première c'est le moment clé
l'éducation moment clé pour tous nos
jeunes qui
partent parfois dans la vie avec des
atouts qui sont assez différents et l'é
colol est là pour permettre à chacun de
s'exprimer pleinement et puis surtout
pour moi l'école est la principale
mission d'aider à former le libre
arbitre et la capacité de jugement de de
nos jeunes gens et c'est
particulièrement important dans un monde
où nous sommes entourés de fausses
nouvelles de complotisme de réseaux
sociaux qui racontent un peu n'importe
quoi trier le vrai du faux faire
fonctionner ces neur et son intelligence
je crois qu'au-delà de la transmission
des connaissances c'est la mission
essentielle de l'école c'est donc elle
est tout à fait au centre de ce que
peut-être une soci la République au f et
d'ailleurs vous avez appelé à la fin de
votre intervention les les étudiants
l'espérance hein euh est-ce que
justement oui dans un monde où on est un
peu noyé comme ça par le
complottisme des des des fake news euh
justement bah les études le le
l'apprentissage ça permet justement de
de de se débarrasser de ça d'avoir
peut-être un peu plus
d'espérance vous savez nous avons
plusieurs plusieurs jeunesses en fait
dans notre pays il y a une jeunesse qui
est embarquée dans de bonnes études et
puis ensuite dans des métiers porteurs
elle est à l'aise et puis il y a une
jeunesse qui est laissé de côté c'est ça
qui est la principale préoccupation
cette inégalité qui s'est créé pour ceux
que j'ai
rencontré ce soir j'ai voulu
effectivement leur dire d'abord ne
croyez pas ceux qui vous disent que
c'était mieux avant quand on jete regard
sur le 20e siècle on se rend compte que
ça n'a pas êté un siècle paisible ni
finalement tellement sympathique et puis
surtout de vous laissz pas intoxiqué par
cette espèce d'autoflagéation que nous
attendons matin midi et soir tout Foug
tout sa fesse nous avons des problèmes
nous avons des défis formidable devant
nous le défi climatique le défi
migratoire le défi numérique aussi
puisque l'intelligence artificielle
apporte le pire et le meilleur mais si
on résiste si on se bat si on y croit si
on cultive effectivement cette vertu d'
espérance à laquelle j'ai appelé on peut
y arriver et on y arrivera vous même
vous racontez dans dans votre livre
alors après une jeunesse un peu
solitaire mais heureuse à mononde Marçon
puis vous vous allez à Paris dans les
classes préparatoires et puis vous
faites de très brillantes études vous
vous réussissez normal du premier coup
l'agrégation de lre classique puis Lena
euh et il y a toujours une question
alors c'est vrai que tout le monde
reconnaît votre intelligence Chirac
avait dit c'est le meilleur d'entre nous
ça vous a peut-être pas toujours porté
chance mais enfin bon n pas plu à mes
camarades ça pas plu aux autres
euh mais je me suis toujours demandé en
politique au fond votre ami à la main
puisque vous dites que c'est votre ami
dans le livre dit dans son Dictionnaire
amoureux du pouvoir que le le pouvoir de
l'intelligence n'est pas toujours
l'intelligence du pouvoir mais est-ce
que quand on fait je parense plutôt
campagne électoral quand on est
intelligent on a un peu de doute sur
soi-même on est modéré et vous faites
d'ailleurs un éloge de la modération à
travers
montesc est-ce que finalement c'est pas
un
handicap écoutez il vaut mieux être
intelligent gens que saut hein non je
dis pas que les autres sa saut mais ENF
mais on peut peut-être plus douter plus
peut-être mais le doute ça n'est pas
l'inaction ça n'est pas l'indécision
hein ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
que tout le monde monte rapidement aux
extrêmes la vie politique s'hystérise la
vie politique devient violente aussi je
crois qu'il n'y a rien de bon à attendre
cette évolution je crois qu'au contraire
le retour à la modération c'est-à-dire
au temp de la réflexion hein au fait
d'écouter les autres à la tolérance et
puis à un moment ou un autre de décider
bien sûr il faut prendre des décisions
et agir je crois que c'est ça la bonne
voie et je suis heureux de voir que
quand je dis ça dans mes rencontres à
propos de mon livre assez souvent je
vois des gens venir vers moi et me dire
ça fait du bien d'entendre parler de
modération dans le monde un peu tumultu
dans notutre monde c'est vrai qu'on en a
moins l'habitude quand on quand on
écoute notamment les les chaînes de de
télévision continue et cetera euh
peut-être vous allez rencontrer
peut-être des étudiants tout à l'heure
il y a peut-être un qui voudrait vous
dire moi je voudrais absolument faire de
la politique et vous l'encouragerez
peut-être et si quelqu'un vous disait ah
non moi la politique non j'en veux pas
ouais ce deuxième cas sera sans doute
plus fréquent que le premier parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut bien reconnaître
la politique est une réputation
désastreuse les hommes politiques sont
réputés menteurs impuissant ou pourri
dernier sondage donne des résultats à
nouveau tout à fait catastrophiques et
j'ai essayé de dire dans mon livre que
ce n'est pas la réalité bien sûr qu'il y
a des moutons noirs dans la politique il
y en a partout dans toutes les
professions peut-être pas plus
qu'ailleurs et en tout cas l'immense
majorité des hommes politiques je les ai
bien connus pendant les 30 ou 40 années
où j'ai été immergé dans ce bain il
s'engagent pour servir pour servir le
bien commun
euh à la disposition de leurs
concitoyens et donc je plaide pour la
noblesse de l'englagement politique vous
voyez que je n'hésite pas à aller à
contrecourant de l'opinion générale un
dernier mot peut-être justement vous
dites dans dans votre libre j'ai eu une
vie politique une vie politique remplie
évidemment enfin ça tout le monde le
sait mais euh j'ai été équilibré aussi
par une vie privée heureuse euh vous
pensez que oui l'un ne va pas sur
l'autre je pense que la la vie privée
est d'abord très importante la politique
n'a pas été toute ma
vie ma vie professionnelle entre
guillemets ça n'a pas été toute ma vie
personnelle et je pense que c'est un
élément important je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tous les repères auxquels
les Français étaient attachés dans
l'histoire tout ce qu' FA la cohésion de
notre société et le sens de la vie est
en train de s'effacer euh la religion la
France se déchristianise la famille le
père la mère et les enfants c'est plus
tout à fait le modèle le travail ou bien
on reste chez soi ou bien quand on va au
travail on a plus son bureau c'est les
bureaux flexibles et cetera je ne porte
pas de jugement de valeur je constate
simplement ces évolutions et je
comprends que les Français ont besoin de
se rattacher à quelques principes
fondamentaux et de ce point de vue la
famille quel que soit sa forme est un
élément absolument essentiel ça a été un
élément B équilibre parce que j'ai connu
des succès dans ma vie j'ai connu des
échecs aussi oui et dans l'échec on a
besoin c'est pour ça que je parlais de
l'intelligence des campagnes d'être
soutenu bien sa compte et j'ai eu cette
chance et ben je vous remercie je je
rappelleir le titre de votre livre je
vous renvoie votre levoir quand même
beaucoup plus sur vous s'appelle donc
une histoire française et c'est chez
taandier merci beaucoup an Jupé merci à
vous